Let's spend just a few minutes
talking about clemency.
Clemency is the power which the president,
United States has governors have.
And some states,
pardon?
Pardon?
And parole boards have to
commute or preve or forgive a,
uh,
a crime in a particular case.
Uh,
normally not subject to judicial review.
Important.
Just to make a couple
of distinctions here,
pardon,
is to forgive a person completely,
uh,
for the sentence.
They're no longer under any judicial,
uh,
comp,
you know,
supervision,
uh,
whatever.
They're no longer being
punished for their crime.
Uh,
clemency is reducing the crime.
For example,
what comes up most often in capital cases
is that the governor or the pardon and
parole board,
whoever has the authority
in that particular state,
uh,
Ken Commute the death
sentence to life imprisonment.
So the person is still subject to spending
life in prison or spending a certain
number of years in prison.
Uh,
but not the death sentence.
Any sentence can always be commuted
to a shorter sentence to time served.
For example,
in a non capital case,
a reprieve is when the governor or
whoever has the authority just simply
temporarily halts and execution perhaps
to get more information or to have time,
uh,
to uh,
consider some factors
or consult some people,
uh,
with regard to the decision.
And that happens not very often,
but from time to time.
Now,
these are not to in any way
be confused with parole.
Uh,
which means that a person
who sends a serving a prison,
sins is released on parole.
They're still under sends,
they can be revoked and brought back,
or a person who's on probation,
uh,
who is just basically allowed to
serve their sentence in the community.
Uh,
but very often at the end of the process,
whether it's a person in the federal
system who will apply to the president of
United States,
uh,
for clemency or,
and one federal death case was
commuted by President Bill Clinton.
Uh,
Ronald Chandler's Destin's was commuted
from death to life imprisonment or more
likely in the states.
Uh,
there'll be an appeal to the
governor for a clemency in a case.
A historically clemency has been
given more often than it is today,
although it is given
from time to time today.
Uh,
Edmond Brown,
who was the governor of California
in the late fifties and early 1960s,
actually wrote a book
about his experience,
uh,
in terms of handling clemency
request there in California.
It's called public justice private mercy.
Uh,
and he talks about the decisions he made,
the considerations that went into them.
Uh,
he granted 23,
uh,
and he denied 36,
so 36 people were executed.
23 people were granted clemency.
That's a much higher rate of granting
clemency than we see in any state today.
Uh,
so far,
uh,
with the death penalty,
we've had,
uh,
at least at the end of 2020 13,
we had had,
uh,
about 1300 death sentences carried
out in the United States and 273 ca
mutations.
But several of those
commutations are a large number,
uh,
were accounted for by a,
a very,
you know,
a few governors,
uh,
modern practices in for Texas for example,
there's almost no clemency for,
there's no meaningful clemency process.
There's a huge board of 18
people that never meets,
uh,
that denies in virtually every case.
The governor doesn't have as
much power as most people think.
In Texas.
The governor cannot commute
a death sentence unless the
pardon and parole board,
uh,
recommends the governor can grant
reprieves that is temporarily halt an
execution.
Uh,
but the real power is with the board,
which is not inclined
to commute sentences.
Uh,
the most,
uh,
people commuted and certainly at one time,
was in Illinois by Governor George Ryan.
Uh,
Governor Ryan,
who had been a supporter of the death
pony and voted for it when he was a
Republican member of
the state legislature,
uh,
after becoming governor.
And after seeing a number of
people exonerated sometimes
by journalism students
at Northwestern University,
uh,
begin to have grave concerns about
the death penalty in Illinois.
Uh,
he appointed a commission
that looked into it,
found that there were a number of problems
with the death penalty that a number
of people who were innocent,
uh,
at the time,
Anthony Porter was exonerated not
long after Governor Ryan took office.
There had been 13 people
exonerated and only 12 executed.
So the percentages weren't very
good in terms of Illinois stuff.
Polly governor Ryan became convinced
that for more people on death row were
innocent,
he pardoned those people.
Uh,
and then in 2003,
he commuted the entire death row,
167 people,
uh,
from the death pony,
two sentences in prison.
So that was one of the,
uh,
as the largest number of
people to leave death row,
except for when the Supreme Court decided
the case of Furman versus Georgia,
which resulted in,
uh,
in all the states,
basically,
uh,
vacating the death sentences and going to,
to life imprisonment on those cases.
Uh,
the extent to which the courts could
get into this was challenged in,
um,
uh,
Ohio adult parole
authority versus Woodard.
A case that went to the Supreme Court in
1997 and the argument was how much due
process,
how much fairness,
what procedures is a person entitled
to a that's going to have clemency.
And it was sort of started by the fact
that the board and Ohio was going to
interview Woodard and
what it was complaining.
Uh,
first of all,
it,
it was too short a notice.
There wasn't time to prepare,
uh,
wanted to have a lawyer there,
but board wouldn't allow that.
Uh,
and then it could make a
statement to the board,
but then there was some concern
with that would be used for,
although at this point of the process,
um,
probably,
uh,
Megan statement to the board is in
an effort to convince it is probably
something most people would do.
A,
at any rate,
the Supreme Court of the United States
said that there's no substantive
expectation of clemency.
Clemency is an act of grace by the
executive according to the court,
uh,
is not part of determining
guilt or innocence.
Uh,
it's committed to the
authority of the executive.
Uh,
and there's no fifth amendment
right to remain silent.
I guess if a person doesn't
want to talk to the board,
uh,
they don't have to.
Uh,
but on the eve of execution,
um,
maybe more important to talk to the
board then to exercise one's a fifth
amendment rights.
Uh,
justice O'Connor concurring,
uh,
she said the protections for someone
in the clemency process are minimal,
but there are some,
she said,
for example,
if a,
they just flipped a coin and decided
who got clemency or who not based on,
uh,
how the coin flip came out.
Or if some people were just arbitrarily
denied any clemency process at all,
that might be a due process concern.
Uh,
justice Stevens,
uh,
took the position that there were
particular guarantees to a person,
uh,
facing clemency for a fair process.
Uh,
he pointed out that appeal,
it always surprises people,
but there's no right to appeal a,
every state provides for an appeal and
the federal government provides for
appeals.
And the Supreme Court has held that
when something is a universal practice,
such as that you have a right to a lawyer,
transcripts,
all,
all of the necessary,
all the things necessary
to handle an appeal.
He said,
why is this any different?
Uh,
basically the federal government and
the states all provide for some clemency
process.
And so there ought to be
some sort of protections,
maybe minimal,
but some protections,
uh,
for people,
in the process.
The bottom line is that this
case is pretty much said,
uh,
this is going to be up to the governor
or up to the pardon and parole board and
states that have it.
Uh,
I should say just a few states,
Georgia being one.
Uh,
the governor has no authority whatsoever.
It's decided by a board
of pardons and parole.
In some other states.
The governor has completed 30 and
can do whatever he or she wants to,
uh,
and yet other states,
the board,
uh,
right,
makes a recommendation to the governor
will often interview the person who's
going to be executed or will receive
information from both the prosecution and
the,
the condemned persons lawyers.
Uh,
make a recommendation to the governor.
some states the governor can either
accept or ignore that recommendation.
Uh,
some states the governors bound
by the recommendation if the,
if the board doesn't authorize it,
uh,
then the governor cramp can't grant
clemency the most extreme examples,
Pennsylvania,
which has a five member board,
uh,
which has to be unanimous
before the governor,
uh,
can,
commute a death sentence or a
sentence of life without parole.
Uh,
this was because,
uh,
when a mutation was granted
of a life sin sometime ago,
uh,
and the person,
three,
three to two vote of the board and the
person went out and committed other
crimes,
uh,
the Pennsylvania Constitution
was amended to say,
now the vote has to be unanimous.
So very,
very,
it's going to be very difficult
for anybody to have a commutation,
uh,
in,
in the state of Pennsylvania.
But it differs from state to state,
uh,
in terms of who decides and the power.
But primarily it's going to
be the executive branch is
going to be the governor.
Uh,
in most states,
uh,
reasons that,
governance have granted.
We just look at why
have some people gotten,
uh,
out on,
or excuse me,
had their death sentences commuted,
uh,
during the last 40 years.
Uh,
doubts about guilt.
It's probably one of the most compelling.
Sometimes the governor will say,
Ah,
I'm not convinced this person is innocent.
Uh,
but on the other hand,
I have enough doubts
about their innocence,
uh,
that I'm not going to
let them be executed.
A oral Washington was
such a person in Virginia,
uh,
in his case,
the governor of Virginia,
Governor Wilder,
uh,
had enough reservations about his guilt
that he commuted his sentence to life
imprisonment turned out
good thing that he did.
Uh,
because later DNA evidence proof that
Washington was completely innocent and had
absolutely nothing to do
with the murder at all.
Uh,
the same thing happened with governor
Taft in Ohio and Jerome Campbell's case,
uh,
this wasn't a case that
turned out as clear cut.
Is there a Washington's,
but it was a case where
there just was not a,
just not enough certainty,
uh,
with regard to guilt.
And so the governor commuted the sentence
of the person's still serving life
imprisonment.
Uh,
but at least it's not executed.
So that if some additional information,
and in other cases like this,
if some additional information comes to
light as it did in rural Washington's
case,
uh,
the person will still be alive and can
get back to the rest of their lives.
Uh,
another is the role of the person,
uh,
in the crime.
Governor,
uh,
Kernan of Illinois granted that,
granted clemency in the
case of Darnell Williams,
uh,
because of that,
because of his role in the
crime compared to others.
Uh,
other factors,
sometimes his mental illness and
the person's a role in the crime.
Uh,
Michael Daniels,
again,
same governor,
uh,
of Indiana granted a
clemency in that case,
committed to case to life in prison.
Uh,
in that case,
the victim's son was supporting
a commutation of the sentence,
which probably,
uh,
certainly contributed to the governor,
making a decision about it.
Uh,
the Georgia,
uh,
board of pardon and parole,
commuted the Destin's right when he
was about to be executed of Alexander
Williams.
Uh,
this was a man who was tremendous,
incredibly mentally ill,
uh,
was forcibly medicated by the prison
in order to keep him manageable.
Uh,
he was a juvenile at
the time of his crime.
This was when it was still possible to
execute people who are juveniles at the
time of their crime.
Um,
the,
uh,
just to show how disturbed,
Alexander Williams was a,
after the board commuted his sentence
and he went to service life since just a
very short time after that,
he committed suicide and
ended his life that way.
Uh,
another reason is that some people
just ultimately the board finds a,
these people are,
uh,
not appropriate for the death pony,
for reasons that may not have
been presented to the jury,
but are now known.
One of those was a Willie James Hall,
uh,
in Georgia.
Uh,
he had no prior record.
He had good to conduct
in prison and even had a,
one of the things that is most unusual,
the prosecutor said that life imprisonment
without parole would be okay with
him.
So after Georgia had convicted
this man since him to death,
gone through the appellate process,
gone through all the review process,
um,
the board commutes,
the sentenced to life imprisonment and
hall is serving life in prison instead of
having been executed.
Uh,
another example is gale
Owens in Tennessee.
Uh,
her case became quite the cause there.
at one point she was a battered spouse,
uh,
who was,
sentenced to death.
One of the,
uh,
she hired somebody to kill her husband.
Uh,
and one thing that happened in
her case is they offered a plea,
which would have spared
her the death pony.
She wanted to take the plea,
but the prosecution said,
well,
only if the codefendant,
only if the,
the hitman would take it.
Uh,
and he would not take it.
so she was sort of drug into a capital
trial against her will and was sentenced
to death.
You know,
she was a model inmate while on death row.
And the governor looked at her case
and then looked at a lot of other cases
where people in similar situations,
particularly battered women
who had killed their spouses,
uh,
and concluded that the death pony was,
was out of line for her.
And ultimately a commuted her sentence,
not very long after her
sentence was commuted,
she was paroled,
uh,
and return to the community.
So one day she's facing execution
and not that long afterwards,
CCI,
she is actually out in the community.
Uh,
and then life circumstances,
uh,
mitigating evidence that maybe
it wasn't presented at trial.
I mean,
two cases of this or,
uh,
Joseph Murphy in Ohio,
who was beaten and starved
and sexually abused.
And all of these things
that happen to him,
uh,
resulted in ultimately the governor,
granting,
uh,
or commuting his case,
granting clemency in his case so
that he wasn't executed by Ohio.
Uh,
in Delaware.
same reason basically for,
uh,
Robert Gaddis death
penalty being a commuted,
uh,
just the most horrific sexual abuse,
imaginable visited upon
Gaddis when he was a child.
There was some question
about the reliability of this
because it hadn't had come
out earlier.
Uh,
the pardon and parole board and making
their recommendation to the governor
said,
even if half this information is true,
uh,
this man shouldn't be executed.
Uh,
and that recommendation was,
uh,
accepted by the governor.
Uh,
and,
uh,
his sentence was commuted
to life in prison.
It's just a couple of other observations
that I would make about the clemency
process.
Uh,
first of all,
in most states,
uh,
it's very unpredictable
and it's very political.
If the number,
if a number of executions
have been carried out,
then the governor may feel
like a case can be commuted,
uh,
because he's already shown how tough
he is by executing other people.
On the other hand,
if it's been a long time since any
[inaudible] anybody's been executed,
uh,
governor may be very reluctant to commute
a sins no matter how compelling the
case,
uh,
because it might create an uproar.
Uh,
so where people are in the queue to
be executed can be very important.
Once the governor's granted a commutation,
in one case,
very unlikely that,
that,
that the governor's going to grant
a Comutation in the next case.
Uh,
so,
uh,
those kind of political factors,
I mean,
Edmond Brown in his book,
uh,
about,
computations that he granted as
governor and talked about in one,
he didn't do it because he
didn't want to alienate,
uh,
a legislator who's vote he needed,
for a program that he was supporting.
Uh,
the other thing is that in places that
have part in parole boards or where
information has just submitted to the
governor in some places where there is no
board to make a recommendation
to the governor,
uh,
the information is just provided,
to the governor's lawyer,
the governor's legal counsel.
Uh,
but regardless of whether it's
provided to a board or the council,
at least in my experience,
most of the time,
uh,
it's sort of a star chamber proceeding.
Uh,
the person who's condemned can submit
any information and letters and all kinds
of supporting information saying,
here's why I'm entitled to parole.
On the other hand,
people who po kind
mutation on the other hand,
uh,
people who oppose commutation can
submit all sorts of letters and uh,
and can say all sorts of things about
the person accused the person of crimes.
Maybe they didn't commit,
but that information is not
shared with a condemned person.
So you don't know what the board or
what the governor is considering or the
governors advisors,
uh,
are considering.
Uh,
and it may very well be that there's
information in there that's false,
that's not right,
but there's no opportunity to rebut it,
uh,
because you don't know what it is.
Uh,
so very different from a court process
where there's notice of what the
information is.
There's an opportunity to cross examine.
There's an opportunity
to rebut the evidence.
Uh,
none of that in most states.
in the clemency process,
it's a very sort of closed process.
It's often a very informal process,
uh,
in terms of how,
the governor exercises a clemency,
but it's a critically important process.
The Supreme Court said in
Herrera Versus Collins,
uh,
the case in which it said there no
such thing as a free standing claim of
innocence.
Uh,
the court said this is what
a commutation powers for,
uh,
that,
if a person has a claim of innocence,
uh,
they can present it.
But of course there's no guarantee,
uh,
that the governor is going to
be receptive to that claim.
But as we've seen,
there may be other things that
governors are receptive to.
Uh,
it may differ from governor to governor
and one state has the governor who's
more compassionate and grants a
clemency and cases the next governor,
it's not going to do that.
Maybe the next governor
is a career prosecutor.
He doesn't want to grant
clemency any cases.
So there are a lot of political factories
and other facts and other vagaries
that sorta go into this process of whether
or not someone receives clemency or
not.
Uh,
generally this is the last decision
that's made before someone's put to death.
Uh,
this was a decision that Bill Clinton
made in the case of Ricky ray rector a,
that when he decided to
deny clemency for rector,
which of course was he was politically
compelled to do because he was on the
ballot and the New Hampshire primary,
uh,
that sealed the fate of Reiki rector.
And as a result,
he was put to death in that case.
And generally that's the clemency
decision is going to seal the fate of most
people facing the death Polly,
how that comes up.
Okay.